[Music]
it may look like a western but in the
adaptation of thomas savage's novel
benedict cumberbatch brings to life a
story drenched in toxic masculinity i
wonder
what little lady made these
actually i did sir inwardly masochistic
rancher phil burbank represses his
desires outwardly he bullies those
closest to him
they're just as
real as possible it is a take on
masculinity by a filmmaker best known
for telling the female experience oscar
winning director jane campion her first
feature film in 12 years and her first
with a male protagonist
she's always been a heroine of mine that
piano was a sort of seismic film when i
was growing up for me and
i just completely fell under its spell
while the story may be set in 1920s
montana its exploration of masculinity
raises issues we're still talking about
today you get this sort of
rebellion aspect or this sort of denial
this sort of childish defensive position
of
um
not all men are bad and blah blah and
it's like no we just have to shut up and
listen we need to fix the behavior of
men and to understand that you have to
kind of lift
the lid of the engine a little bit
now 25 years since jane campion won the
palm door many had predicted it would
pave the way for other women to follow
suit but only now post me too are we
finally seeing more female directors
come through
yeah it does feel like a painfully long
road compared to where she began she has
inspired people all along the way it's
like mental health you know these things
are still a stigma there's still
something that
needs talking about need addressing
needs writing and and help with and
you know until there's equal pay place
at the table and equality across the
board of every kind you know we still
have to have that conversation
cumberbatch had nicotine poisoning three
times through smoking so much in
character
he also had to play the banjo and
castrate bulls
method acting which required a strong
stomach but that might just pay off come
awards season
casey spencer sky news